each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
computer vision can such as object
recognition is that although we know a
lot about how the life is transformed we
know a lot about the physics a light
generated reflective of services
projects to this camera to the canvas
and we don't know a lot about how the
image is perceived by the human so these
tasks or for example recognizing a
building here making impress about what
type of building in this say the tower
properties of the building how many
windows it has a high and so on all
these kind of properties that we could
infer it's really happening inside this
person's head here on business or only
for them going to limit and now how
humans all these tasks is more and then
a lot of humans agree about a lot of
things so and does matter which human
you put there they will agree that
there's ability has the tower create
certain distance and by the task is
reading a bigger so there's no objection
way we put for example we find optative
text without asking tumors what certain
objects are it's a little bit one of the
big benefits in computer vision you can
ask people to provide a scroll to state
and compare that with with other
scientific disciplines that have used
machinery so if I want to know whether
certain protein binds to a certain
receptor itself an objective question
and I might not be able to measure it
but with some with some effort i could
probably obtain a definite answer to
that question here i have to trust
agreement to make give that answer to me
in fact that task is really defined by
this room at night and i can extract
training daylight and extract
annotations from the too many research
and think that sells computer vision
apart is that we have lots of us for
image data available in fact it's
growing in the last 15 years
in a very rapid pace the lessee
properties together are really strong
argument in favor of using machine
learning too salty higher vision now the
question is what kind of models should
be able to do so two sources didn't ask
let's take a look first at the
television tasks that we have sold or
reasonably thought it's I need to see
examples and are more so here's an
example of image retrieval and meshing
here's an example of frontal face
detection and here's an example of image
stratification and for all these tasks
we now have computer models that achieve
performance close to or sometimes
superior of humans so for this is our
together we just have to decide whether
these two images show the same objects
and then maybe to register them in a way
but the key question whether they
represent the same object any kind of
combining the exact positioning the
weather conditions here every digital
camera you bought in the last five years
proves to you that the star so we can
attack frontal face is quite low image
stratification we can easily sort images
into a few hundred categories
indoor-outdoor certain kind of
landscapes computers handle that quite
well and what these tasks have in common
is that they all be successfully reduced
to a simple decision class so to
classification are these cars the same
yes I know classification of the entire
image and we can collect training get by
writing explains of a notation so we can
just ask humans are these images showing
the same the same object and what they
also in come on there's simple shadow
models are say on the art so simple say
linear classification models expect a
run on our many features are cheating
state of the art forms now let's a look
at the tasks that we have not solved
here that are really challenging
television today so he has to be
examples human post estimation for
national images seen understanding where
we want to for each pixel infer some
kind of interpretations a surface
orientation type of object object
classification for general general
object classes very model recognize all
possible ships in the world and all
support and becoming more important
action activity and gesture recognition
where you want to recognize something
from video the least ask have in common
that we want to predict at the same time
multiple dependent variables we don't
just want to decide yes or no for the
class but we want to make a joint
decision say about all the positions of
the joints in the body or we want to
decide for every pixel look at the same
time what class it is nose and we have
seen that structure models as I will be
talking about an armada of the top have
really made progress increasing the
performance on these tasks however these
structured models are fundamentally
intractable and so we have to use our
proxy nations and so the questions and
which approximation so we use how do
they can form and what how to do it and
trade up to you make and this is
basically the remainder of the talk we
want to understand and improve the
typical models for these high television
times with the goal of eventually
hopefully solving it um so when I talk
about model I essentially needs a simple
function f that faces argument an
element from the set X which is a domain
and produces a prediction in a set why
it's a very simple idea I left something
from X to Y for example given an RGB
image X in further desperate case but we
want some blame ourselves in RGB image X
improbable presence at position of all
object and image so for example here
input X infirm all these bounding boxes
plus a class labels would be one simple
representation now i'm off to set up
this function because it seems like i'm
eating
to set up and well you can see graphical
models as a language to be finds mapping
to make predictions but in general this
Magnemite be ambiguous so you cannot
make this mess in your neatly and there
might be different reasons for example
you might not have enough measurements
to make that prediction it might be
interesting uncertainty because they you
include yourself so you cannot infer
something that you don't perceive
directly and so in many is ambiguous and
the probabilistic graphical models allow
you to define this matter holistically
so in this case you can define either a
conditional or joint probability so for
another year conditional probability
game extend observed English give me an
N type of the distribution of all
possible configurations why this is how
you can you find this page typically for
for this talk i will use what's known as
an undirected this cream conditioner
metal field never heard of it and don't
mind but it's defined by my means of an
energy function and we find probability
proportional to some function of his
attachment 1 per degree and we need to
teresa at all our models is a concept of
a loss function so last time she tells
you if you predict something and
something else is true what is the
penalty yourself and we will generally
assume that the loss function is given
to us it depends on the task of this
thing but now give you the loss function
and given the true world distributions
or the true joy or conditional
distribution over the world we can
evaluate the quality of our predictions
and we can evaluate it as the expected
loss that we will suffer if you predict
f of X so this is the expectation over
the world distribution of our prediction
and the loss of perspiration ok if this
is low we create well if it is high for
many many hours now the problem is we
don't have the true waters to try if you
look at it we
have solved all the problems so what we
do instead is we we set up a probability
distribution of probability models we
start now updated to become close to the
word solution and then we replace the
word distribution with our modern usage
and as the assumption that our model
somehow reflects the words okay so this
is a general concept of how you make
predictions in these models as a summary
we set up some probabilistic model I'm
giving an example in a minute we have we
have some training data which is assumed
to be a sample from the world
distribution we combine it using some
estimation procedure to infer what did
it work with our belief of the world is
and I'll give this probability exclusion
King the loss function we can derive the
sanction after that tells us how to
predict and once we have this function
we care for a new image X became very
assumption to make prediction why stop
okay so let's see the general and the
general idea here however there is an
alternative concept slightly different
which is called direct crystallization
where we simply set up such function
directly have second samples from the
world distribution and have the loss
function given and we do something you
this case we minimize directly the loss
that we have on our training samples
plus an extra regularization phone and
he obtained directly such a function and
once we have became the new test image X
we can move that we can evaluate this
function by minimizing this energy so
the energy conservation industry it's
just a different way and both are
popular both are popularly used
especially in division now the question
is and do they behave differently in
different regimes are they saying there
she is the same as topically for what
way off here the differences also a good
question yeah give me an example of why
you might need a non-uniform loss
function while some of us were like I
said like don't predict that somebody's
holding a gun if they're willing right
so an example I night and I wasn't sure
when I cross the street that there's no
car on the right side coming approaching
but ninety nine percent confidence it's
not enough how it still looked at
because my lost hunters me I'm an arrow
and I go forward and they say car coming
the boss would be very much so this is
the loss function last transfer what you
believe about the world it with how you
make decisions and depending on the loss
function which might be different for
different people so some people are more
risk blowing they are you make different
decisions ok so and in the next part of
this hub I'm going to this is the inside
part so I want to understand this two
different concepts of making inferences
and the task and most useful this is a
simplified house it's a proxy task force
that is very challenging so I gave the
noisy image to speak so wise any kind of
noise Gaussian noise and I will trade
firm and unknowing so this is original
immature where I add moisture and it's
my invitation basically so i want to go
from here to here and these two dancers
should look as close as possible right
now why is it challenging challenging
because any method that successfully
this task has to know something about
natural images if i ignore something
about natural images i'm going to make
this I going to solve this house for me
very badly but if I know that for
example lies continuous and natural
interest so like it could be continuous
be good and start today's by sharing and
the simple model i'm using yes the
street are directed to render view this
fact over application so essential but
essentially said i have some observe
pixel here the noisy pixel and I want
waiting for a variable rate variable
that is the lid annoys pics already okay
and I couple leads using in interaction
that someone says I'm preference if I
also say so regular in heated and I'm
more likely to make prediction your
surgeries now it's a couple then the
Cowboys fashion such that if I predict a
certain value here then the pics of nice
work is more likely to produce another
but I don't know the parameter of these
interactions and this is what I'm going
to learn and as loss function I always
you see the mean square off this is just
this is good the squared error and each
pixel versus the ground rules and then
the mean of all pixels now i'm going to
play little year i'm actually simulating
the world so i'm completely controlled
in the world distribution here because
the completely controlled by
distribution i came up with the analyzes
heading in sort of closed box and hope
am I doing this I actually take the same
model with some fixed para need as I i
choose to generate my data and then I
know the generative model and then I can
try to recover the generating model
using different methods so we easily the
maximum likelihood estimation here use
the risk minimization okay and I fix
this this parameter C are basically the
function that is decent erection so
these are paralyzed by bison 16 scalar
values each I choose East according to
this I'm going to propose one single
braunfels English I had pics Awakening
and annoys plug into my model with these
parameters and for this model because
the probabilistic I can solve as many
times as I want I get a training set and
now I try to recover these parameters in
this case or I try to recover a
prediction confidence
to deal with as close as possible things
okay so this is a setting that I control
the world this is just a situation they
look roughly the same all these messes
pretty good pretty obviously
qualitatively but if you look at it
quantitatively in terms of a mean square
error then an interesting thing happens
so the red one is the maximum likelihood
estimator using this mean squared error
loss when making predictions so the
first pipeline basically as I use
multiple samples I recover the true
model and then finding optimal
predictions so I cannot get better than
that for the risk minimization one it
let us out before that and actually as
atomically I don't make the optimal
prediction slice up what does it mean to
make many samples now you get many duty
noise images yes I get many pounds of of
noisy observations and denoise ground
rules so this is not about em and I can
control that way and the more I the more
samples I have the more I can learn
about the true generating model the more
I can learn about the parity does at the
walk closer my beliefs come get to the
true world and therefore make better
decisions so this is a generative model
and this is a parameter the last load is
quite close here this is this is a
generative model and this is a maximum a
good estimate on five minutes office the
original age estimate because of the cop
has already the loss function looks
quite different and in fact it should
not look like this so it just looks
there now it's not easy to understand
but let me interpret is for you the
essentials we if you're setting the
model class i'm using actually because I
simulate the world it contains a true
model let's Akita the model class
contains a true model hmm my estimate i
use mega mega
estimator not simulate into this case is
not to be consistent what this means is
that I get more observations I get
closer and closer to the true parameter
and because this is so the more they
don't month I observe I get increasingly
accurate model to the estimation error
goes to zero and because I get more my
current model memories about the work
get more no closets been sugar to world
and so and I mean the best possible
predictions because I believe exactly
what the what the word distribution less
that's why this is this is expenses
without basically now the big problem is
the first assumption the first
assumption is and that the model class
contains a true model and this is quite
amazing because in practice if I use
such a simple model it will not contain
the true model they generated by yield
natural images and the noisy version so
let's test the more realistic a so a
case where I use the two simple model to
try to estimate a more complicated and
how how am I going to do this basically
I use a safe set up now but I sample my
train data from a more complicated
distribution and I do this by using an
extra additional set of parameters which
is associated to an extra set of
interaction so the reading of
interaction serum simulate some
interactions of variables are to the
displacement of two apart so we capital
something that is not present in the
model that I fit right so the deck i
generate is more complicated has some
interactions that i hold accountable and
i'm going to do this in a way that i
have a scalar epsilon here such
different answer episode 20 these
interactions from playing role but when
i said epsilon to strictly off the 0 I
get the more complicated model and the
more I increase
strong as it actually comes this is the
same setup but I just sounded more
complicated model I still estimate the
original policy model gear and the
energy hunter to fight for the expect
well the interesting is out here is that
once I increases excellent constant the
Miss specification factor when it mrs.
game is 0 then it's as it was this is a
vitamin sample not here for five no
silent but once I encrease text normally
both models become worse because they
are using the wrong model but there is
some point where they cross over and the
risk in Malaysian approach as a lower
expected loss of the old master so this
interest the question is this is all
synthetic do we observe of your data the
answers yes we do so this is really
noisy data and we observe that say this
is a this is a maximum value estimated
model minimize the great loss a test
time is a gene certain mean squared
error if I choose the diversity relation
is she for the same energy function I
achieve LOL mean square cover have or
vice versa for the pizza huge noise
ratio which is the quality measure is
measured in decibels I achieve a higher
fidelity this is a real denoising
benchmark right and because we have a
conditional model we want to make a set
of the art denoising method we can
actually incorporate the best non
denoising model as a feature into our
model and we still observe the same
relative mean area but now we actually
slightly even say all the other night
but these benchmarks consists of four
pairs of the the jhino is damaged and
the noisy go she actually hasn't learned
there they are just a set of of key
images and they tell you you add a
certain Gaussian with
unsay my to each basil okay so you can
generate as much light as well but but
the key fact here is that actually you
have observed our very simplistic
simulator setting is similar what you're
talking real it so and we ok but by this
inside we obtain the best gonna move it
slightly differently but a silk maybe
small clue oh my i think the images okay
so now the summary of this inside part
is that well typically especially in big
audition the model is wrong we knew that
and what that means is that we have a
two simple model class and that means we
have miss specifications so the true
model is all set all models now it's
fair to ask what happens to various
estimators and learning students when
this is the case and our hearing the
results suggested for the same family of
energy functions that they find the
model that this diary risk minimization
approach can give better results in the
presence of my specification then this
combination of maximum likelihood and
the expected loss minimization intestine
so simple fighting thats related work
which is all interesting slightly
different questions so i think it's
interesting to put it into connection
but also to recognize that has not
meaningfully casually so just one
mention two words Percy down and michael
john and they also analyze miss
specification for models but only for
the lock loss and their turns for the
maximum magnet remains are too so
consistent and the work here in
Cambridge similar custodian for suicide
it's a bigger Mountain they have
analyzed different effect that comes
from approximate inference but I think
there might be a connection so i think
it's it's an interesting observation
that disaster
now you're comparing a second you're
doing it's kind of experimental capacity
yeah yeah white there's a two different
approaches okay well in practice 1c to
be better the other did you get any any
characterization of why it might be so
why is one better than the other or do
we just have to say are we haven't a
clue but one is better than practice i
wish i would have a definite answer form
of a serum but in essence you can
interpret the maximum likelihood
approach as finding a distribution that
mini- the slope loss and that was not
surprising that safe for you for the
applause amazing language made
opportunity now if if you change the
lock loss with some other loss function
you will find a different distribution
it maybe doesn't define institution or
do you find a different set of parameter
so I think it's really the change of
loss function as I said but I don't have
a den amount that so sorry this one and
now I want to refine it first statement
i would say alternative models are all
right because if you have a model s non
parametric and nonparametric really
means at the set of relation that you
can represent grow some more than AC and
if you set up properly and then it can
represent any possible relations if you
see not data and then your mother is
always right okay so it is a limit to a
parametric family that cost some
specification so you can guess for the
next slide will be and the next part are
going to present a non parametric model
for for this time so we call is one of
the decision tree field which is a
combination of decision trees and random
fields right a few studies kind of
models I showed you a decision trees i
will show you in the next slide but
you're probably being a Microsoft here
probably
Avant this moment is the first
combination of these two and also I
believe the first general non parametric
model for this image lately top 100
icing here in this model is that every
direction in the model is conditioned on
the image content and this will have
some nice effect I won't show it's going
to be presented ICCP in a few weeks they
won't say about a non parametric model
is said it should be scalable if you
have not got a model that's not scalable
it's also interesting because you can
only really explore the power at once
you can put me that a lot of daylight to
it so this is really scalable on
permanent home Oh copy that money yeah i
will show you i forgiven on the second
and so decision tree brief summary
decision tree is a tree whistle goes and
are you can imagine decision tree to
work you take a sample X to the tree you
perform a series of tests associate with
the interior north of that tree and
these tests go from X to left or right
so they invaded by the left or right and
you recurse down the tree advocated a
leaf at the leaf not you don't have a
test but you have a model and the models
didn't emerge from X to Y your decision
doing please example I passed a sample X
evaluate the first test at the root nor
the test says right I'm already hitting
a leaf I get a smaller than I evaluate
its modeled on the sample s decision
tree how would I use this pernicious so
how or exactly the semantic segmentation
concept is called for each pixel many
decision into what class represents
computer vision task since motor by a
person shown there the background pixels
I will evaluate this decision tree on
each piece of the image
take a pixel I day put a lid around it
you find some tests based on locally its
features base but not like a test since
i'm basically near the Sun beatin yo
just test the Sun basically as a special
different ways instead of others rather
flexible compelling this test
recursively until I get to a model and
the model is typically in these
applications I interested class label to
just the decision five or two or it's a
glass distribution so I can store it in
things okay the advantage they are very
popular computer vision the image is
that they are non parametric can also
control them what it is easy by how deep
you grow the trees and you have flexible
choice of these tests at the models to
store they are very efficient at test
time additionally efficient at frame
however there's one and obvious
limitation if you look at this if you go
back here to this image if I decide for
certain pics on here that this is a
model by class and I go to the next
person I have to realize that decision
completely so I cannot use the knowledge
that the nearby fix is already in front
of you want to bite off so I basically
make all the decisions conditionally
independent on the image there's not
only say about this but this is an
essential imitation now here's on our
model in this notation which you might
not have seen before this is so I'm
graphical model notation I'm going to
expand into the news wait for at any
pieces I we have one minute variable Y I
and this takes a number of states
discrete States will say ten ten
different states and every piece against
one of these winners variables moreover
the pixel is connected with some
interactions to pieces and relative
offset positions ok so the interaction
see for example goes to the right
neighbor and it all these interactions
are also connected to the image so they
depend on the image and they also
connected to so
weights that defined in action so I
apply this this template on an image say
a 4 by 3 image then I unroll the
template okay then she ate the model and
here i only did all international on the
image of the parent but you get the
picture i can instantiate this model on
arbitrary large tips how to resize so
you fix the template for anyone yes the
toy is completely fixed okay everything
is is fixed but the key here is that
these interactions depends on the image
so although the interaction see here
appears twice a second behave
differently because they are influenced
by the image content of technology lets
how the model is is constructed now what
do we store anything i should write what
do they well basically restore one
decision tree at each type of attack and
this decision tree evaluates a series of
tests as before as for the single pixels
so this would now say give me decision
tree associated to see the next slides
will act on your variables and we
evaluated sequence of tests and instead
of storing a model now at the leaf nodes
we store something at every node and
what we storm is an energy table let's
say to this game for way for table once
we have evaluated a decision tree we sum
the tables along the path and this is
the effective interaction that is active
at this part of the model and because
the path you take depends on the image
content we get different effective
interactions that's the conditional part
of the world depending on the English
content we get a different effective
interaction okay so to complete the
definition of model the these tables
define an energy function the energy
function over all the factors in this
model over all these square holes in the
model define the global energy function
over the entire model and the slope
energy function defines
ability distribution over all possible
creations so that's basic instruction
and now the two questions has somebody
like this before and the other question
is how can we actually learn this big
model right if you measure the megapixel
image it's going to be quite large how's
it coming actually efficiently amount of
smoke now to ask the first question I
related to existing model so this is a
simple random forest model that people
use when we simply drop away all the
Cowboys and higher orbit actions and
only retain the unique items that act on
a single variable only this this is an
hour or notation really and the very
enforcement if we add pairwise
interactions but we use decision trees
of des one so they don't make any test
relate to the image they just simply
store a single energy table we recover
lack of retina fields ok so we strictly
generalize Harbor Brendan fields and
enforcement good they're learning so
learning against the same setting you
get some observed images with ground
troops data and we want to interfer then
the parameters of the model the
parameters of the model now contain a
number of differences but the number and
scope of this factor so which factors
are we going to use how many only go to
use how many variables deliver the tree
structure of this decision tree right
which what decision videos and also
these irritating all the decisions we
notes these are also all currently the
farm work so all these things we have to
choose for now let's assume the Thai
defector types and the trees again based
on their face and we only want to learn
the weights in the tree then the anyway
this Way's Bible for the maximum
likelihood and this has some nice
properties in the small and I want to
explain is now so this is a this is a
super likelihood soon likelihood is a
surrogate like it's not the true
Lattimore
but it's a replacement and it's only
possibility kinds of lightning would if
you have grown to stay huh and what you
do is basically for each pixel which
variable around these pixels you
condition on all the neighbors of that
variable continue fighting the
conditional probability distribution to
be variable at its mark of blanket finds
one term listen lady you do this for all
the pixels and all the training images
do a huge sum here and then you maximize
or minimize the negative looks a little
bit to find a panic so this partial
parametres you can be my sis function
and you can obtain an estimate I'm not
going into too much details here but the
nice comment here our model is that this
function is still a convex function so
the way I said after model the energy
functions linea and the parameters we
don't have any latent variables so the
likelihood the true log likelihood is
the concave function and therefore the
pseudo likelihood lock sitaleki but also
concave function in this case and
negative on comics so tessai
optimization ok so now let's look at
this expression this is computable yes
we can compute this but if we had emails
on thousands of images the first term
you know will become very large you
would have say we have 10 images 1 egg
mix of each you would have 10 million
upset at least now what we do here is
quite simple we recognize that this is
an expectation term over the pixels of
all the images and now once we have
recognizes this expectation term we can
also recognize that you join objective
here is what's known as a competent
objective so it's based on the
expectation and a simple computable
function and now they're different ways
how to approximate the optimization of
this comment or check the function we
could use it points out the stochastic
approximation we take a single rider
mixer from all our main set and perform
an update statement only their people
then we take another random pic system
what me do instead is a simple
deterministic approximation we just
subsample uniform in with replacement a
subset of all the pictures in the
training image in all the 20 images say
a few million five million pieces and we
define this unbiased estimator of the
the original function limiting myself
now what's really interesting here is
all those is quite straightforward thing
to do I think nobody has trained such
structural models on the sub single or
the variable trip and this is what it
makes me really efficient and scalable
to thousands of images okay now
experiments I start with an for
interesting experiment but it's not a
quantitative one but I just want to
catch catch your attention here I've
only starts the Chinese character in
painting task so you give this image and
you are asked to put use this image this
is what we have to do it okay now if you
know about Chinese characters might be
able to do that and we are going to
teach all model to do that we're going
to teach our model the start of chinese
characters and give it 320 images so
chaos of polluted images and fully
observed images and the model has to
infer and learn about the structural
change characters there's a catch we
also give it 100 test images and these
test images show chinese characters
which have not been in the 20 images the
counter smash the characters like could
we say small digits where you have
10,000 teachers of the three anything
this sort of search what it calls to the
radio doesn't work
there is no character office time we
need to learn about the structure
Chinese characters about strokes it is
an impending ask in painting taciturn
recognized to be hard to embedded
quantitatively except the painting
regions very small this already counted
a large ship any region zone and he also
found a positive evaluation we turn out
to be the best but the difference is a
small um so I'm going to just show you
qualitative results here so this is a
test set these characters have not been
interfering that input image this is the
truth handwritten Chinese characters
this is a random force prediction so
where they make decisions can even any
HP so you see something happens here but
it's a very noisy prediction okay and if
you use a mark of rain in fear which
it's not a conditional model but simply
does some smoothing essentially and by
the way this is a very dense connective
models as I said every note is everybody
was connect to 64 acres it's quite a
call for more then what you get is some
interesting smoothing effect so we're
not hearing correctly reasonable the
risk of stroke but you don't mrs. could
use interesting structure itself you
just smooth what your put the decision
tree appeal is that hallucinate so
interesting structure that resembles in
my view of these Chinese characters
right over here this is not not matching
the truce at all but it is really
getting some structure that is plausible
I've lived for three days and finest I
can maybe
okay so but that's just qualitatively so
let's look at a quantity tart instead
and for that we are using the task and
the data set that James shopping and
others have used in this year's cvpr
paper as we use the same task but we are
going to use our decision tree field to
make predictions in these tasks so the
task is given this desk image
observation before ground X image
predict these body parts okay we use the
same features as in a CPR paper so
there's the same but we use a decision
tree filled with which also reasons
about these parallel connections and in
fact we connect variables that are 15
and 20 pieces apart in all horizontal
and vertical directions as well as the
gardening correct direction so we can
make this joint decision more variables
let's go okay this in this case we train
on a single machine so we only use one
thousand pilot training images kind of
50 images for test this is how the day
is it looks like quite diverse because
we won't expect to be my personal me
names where difficult um yes a
qualitative result giving the best in
ish given a random forest jewelry
prediction monitors and now at the top
row you see the mark open field
essentially smoothes this predictions
here and welcome you see the same
connectivity structure this is only
connecting to the neighbors 1 pixel away
it was connecting to the neighbors 15
and 20 pieces of the way you see that
predictions clean up a particular the
labels along the arm is correctly
amusing about okay now let's look at the
numbers person that I'm going to
illustrate you oh I understanding wise
happens when I model where we make our
operations but first let's look at the
numbers the numbers are smaller so here
we have the original number reported in
ECR paper then we essentially get very
similar numbers here with our urine
model so we should say
but additionally we learned the weights
and all these tables even for the
younger trees we get so prudent yeah and
then we add for the market front of you
just basically essentially yet until you
contagion smoothing independent of the
image we get slight improvement the most
traction yet because we can catch them
all the tools to do now when we make a
lot of the traditionals when we actually
use a decision tree field we have
decision trees at Eventide we
consistently again get an improvement so
in the end it advanced to set percent
improvement over the base angle and
trained on one machine this is training
40 hours before water and that sounds
quite a lot quite late quite a large
number but actually it's roughly
comparable with you with performance
report economy the CVR pega wearability
images have been tremendous thousand
course if you wish I remember sir it's
maybe in all of my torso but it still
was such a structured model i think if
they're the first to train on the scales
ok so let's a try to understand why are
you ringing the bell good so this i'm
going to do by means of explaining a
single pairwise interaction as the
action is active between every pair of
pixels as 20 pixels apart horizontally
in the image ok so i want to show you
one image years run to sega shown on the
image and this is interaction 20 pixels
apart so every time two pixels are 20
pixels Apophis interactions active but
is it actually has a decision tree
associated to it and the decision tree
is looking at the local image content
and the decision trees of desk 6 so they
are sorry to leave notes and i'm going
to show you the mean weight issues in
all the leaf nodes moreover at each leaf
node i have one unique paths in this
decision tree and i can sum up all the
energies along this path to obtain
effective interaction and that at that
particular point please and this is one
are they really thought of this power
action and it's effective interaction
this retaining between all the possible
labels right it's certain to weigh very
cool hey did you go to understand but
what we are going to do is we take the
tool largest and smallest value most
repulsive and attractive interactions
between labels and here is an image
we're locally around this area the
interaction from the decision tree
matches the deck observed s image so
there's interact respective and but
because it's active I superimposes
highest largest and smallest entries of
this table on top image as part of the
labor and what we see is here that the
blue arrows reinforce the decisions
consistently off into next okay so what
they do is essentially what they do is
if I observes a certain image past year
then if I labeled right leg then you
should better than a left leg but only
financially English so if we have an
image where it doesn't match here the
image depeche doesn't match then this
direction is not acted so these
conditional smoothing is what what gives
us a good improvement in the polls ok so
this let me briefly summarize the
decision to you and then I'm also kind
of three more minutes for telling you
what we wanted to extend this so
decision tree feels artists committed
mournfulness discreetly much labor costs
and they don't have magic that means the
model has a capacity that can grow the
moderators because the heck they have
the sensation trees it's scalable we can
actually use hundreds thousands of
hundreds or thousands of images on one
machine it's immediately paralyzing also
if you have no machine can scale up
linearly and get the switch into action
without using latent variables which saw
a particular benefit but we get a switch
intensity air conditioning on the
English content and this I think also
knowledge okay now what I show you we
can basically understood a little bit
about how the existing learning approach
popular television are limited by model
the specification that I have motivated
that we want to use a non parametric
model and I've shown you this is not
panic mode and in the future I plan to
continue this work analyze the effect of
this miss verification of the using to
simpler model the sofa decision task and
arrive the set of best practices for the
computer vision practitioner I think we
have already made some progress in that
now it's interesting to use a non
parametric model your mana cost is very
large you represent a lot it becomes
more more important to represent
uncertainty over your molecules this
naturally motivates only non-parent
models but also the Beijing perspective
on conquering also represent somehow
they're even approximate a simplified
form the uncertainty or the normal and
another perspective would be okay I'm
bound to use a parametric what was then
what parent multi-use I suggest some
motivation wants to look into structure
learning what interactions relatable
maybe what features should i use what
factors on air with it all of the goal
is to build better models and better-
make better predictions so that's me the
driving factor in what I have not talked
about here then the general idea is also
applicable to to temporal structure to
them to task by half time for structures
like asthma Josh I ignition an excellent
condition and I developed a jet
recognition system that the trace of
component and particularly additional
dimension of latent seats they catch
rate of accuracy and latency against
each other Michael always have to
generalize across a population and so
it's a challenging research but I'm
proud to say that it actually has a
fruitful application and there's also no
in street or homes and so there's keen
export season to County happen and the
dash recognition code developed here
myself is in the Kinect Sports driving
the National Commission baseball see so
this cooperation was ready
you and there's also cooperation here in
cable to the came to probation team
where we try to make this platform of
this gesture mr. system available to
developers both in terms of my new
suburb outside of Microsoft to quickly
enable this prototyping professional
commercial systems now I mentioned the
three defining task with ICS import
important properties of computer vision
right there was a model uncertainty
there was the task ambiguity I said the
human divides the task in a sense and
this task ambiguity is really
interesting as well because sometimes
you have to go to collect your training
vega and if you want to get
representative training game we better
have a understanding of how you instruct
people to save perform gestures this is
what we what we also had a beautiful
collaboration with computer mediated
living room to analyze how we able to
instruct people together presenter
trained it how did you get more of this
task and guilty resort and that's all
thank you I open to any question you
have sigh and easy plastic lake water oh
yeah well to be honest the DTF is an
instant of a CF right so conditioner I
don't hear this any model where you
where the action somebody pen on the
image content so um the classic Greco
modify exam is here right but in this
graph model you have a fixed very fixed
form of house in texture looks like and
you have two or three remain pantless
etiquette except different various so
the functional form is completely
determined it was in that function of
home you might get juices parents okay
and what we are done here is the
functional form is left to the decision
tree right at each decision tree don't
do it at the leaf node we have a
constant model and what this means is
that giving that late okay with this an
arbitrary partner relationships and as
long as we shoot all tests in such a way
that we can eventually remember all
images by concept but as always be true
to the original we can represent
arbitrary cultural relationships let's
see that you have you played on one with
long time entry the other most primary
car car history have you the little
brothers I actually specifically
negative linear in conversation us use
of approximation to what yes hope we
have extensions to left where I started
having a possible we have a linear
you too and when you have a linear model
you can put out where Peterson for
example you could discourage it crunk a
perilous place and put it in ten bucks
by 10 cars in the engine other ways come
on right see you would enrich the model
because you certainly take combinations
of anything much dependently but you
also can be used in knowledge prior
knowledge that the clock eternity so we
have accepted this as well to to
basically having a linear model why not
even basis hunters and ruining those
said I'm just having a single console
table very simple question but here
essentially modeling the condition of
aspect as spatial where you modeling
especially in the image domain since
then is that does that hold true across
all kinds of the tasks you mentioned or
is it a close enough proximity of the
semantic interpretation yes so the model
parametres in this models don't have
entertaining right there just realizing
energy content that energy function defy
the distribution and then my inference
is about a substitution in the page does
my butt does it hold true in general I
think most of these Marcia prediction
tosin computer vision have some
properties we're giving the local image
content they might still meet an
ambiguity left for example I see ABS of
a gray image patch ok it could be a sky
or could be building patch I don't know
what it is but I know that there's no
edge in this patch I better be smooth
right and this kind of property you can
express you don't have to make a strong
local decision you can just make a
smoothness decision basically do you
want to propagate labels in a certain
way but you don't have to decide on
today more quality and this is what we
see in the connectors web so if I
stretch out my arm if I just show me a
single page on the arm you might not be
able to put the correct our neighbor on
the arm but you can still reason about
the correct Audrey right and so actually
we have a a simple toy house very
exactly simulated that affects me this
is observed image and it just should
decoded into this way this is a snake
where the coloring calls in which
direction bottoms up right down there
are right so locally I really it's very
the biggest you cannot make the decision
because the green line doesn't tell you
would you label this and you need to
propagate any ties around but you can
still make a conditional decision that
you know if I label six you better name
all right and so this is purely other
visual white house to show that we can
do something that same our friend so
good question what I want to ask about
the first part to talk so I'm wondering
you sure bc depth director is musician
could outperform minimizing expected
loss when the model is misspecified
uh-huh so study normal results I said
another result I have not seen it I do
it in this way you can analyze miss
specification in particular Jennifer
just concentrate on yeah I think I think
it's a power seems you know it seems
like you can tribute is set up among to
make that happen so it doesn't see it
doesn't speak very well okay I'm not
making a claim that this has never been
somewhere else polish because it seems
like fundamental issue but I making the
claim that people are generally not
aware of it especially if you go to
community I or machinery I was i have
also not seen any certification issue
being particularly well depressed so
people usually either assume when they
frame of makes it like that
su well they existed to one party that
are an estimated that's a personal issue
a consistent approach wait yeah so I
don't have a definite answer to that
Alberto any point of it I had
interesting discussions already the last
few times I've seen the previous works
you cited and then the ICP argue the
point you're making it all very long so
I disagree so yeah these three works
right this is a very interesting work
they definitely do restricted to the
locals so they fix the last time the
Martin weight-wise work he analyzed if
you use approximate estimation different
techniques how to do actually choose the
right combination of these two are they
making medical decisions and the work
here advise the effect of if you could
represent any possible osteria
overweight but if you're not restricted
to a parent family then beijing offense
is optimal but you might still have to
use the most intractable you might still
have to use an approximate bayesian
inference knackered and then you get
this additional error because use a
consultation first method and so they
analyze this and how you should maybe
bias at any price message to make better
sense of how the expected loss so these
are the worst I'm aware of yeah but any
other point is but I don't know where
other works I will be addressing this
specification under another impact of
making your decisions well what's the
upshot is that should petition using non
parametric model because it seems like
not printed models even specify the
right so yeah yeah there's a lot haven't
models que las being suspect you have to
set a lot of such a way that we ready to
have a baby
you can represent Harry phosphorylation
so the upshot is really be well to
specification and effects on the
estimators and in first procedures how
to use that's gonna be our show how that
translates property let ask I can't give
a conclusive answer today but there's so
many segments khushi so so Sebastian my
question is sort of on the uncertainty
associated with the parameters of the
nonparametric on whether you did this
take transfer to bed and you were
developing this on time for gesture
recognition how important do you think
it is and how easy it is for you to
convey to the developers who are the
finest practitioners who are using the
system of what how to sort of understand
the uncertainties how to choose the
parameters for the model yeah it's a
very question well I guess I mean
everybody this developer saw smart
people right so they understand the
concept of authority and they understand
the concept of training of the different
components in the system as a whole so
we didn't really have problems in
conveying the obvious a probabilistic
white but yet they know that they have
my decision with a fire certain
investment and eventually a certain see
when so we provided them the necessary
understanding to that source but we
didn't have a particularly
they are quite quite receptive to the
idea of getting a certain estimates and
set of definite decisions I people
rather than a calibration procedure that
can given a whole data set determines
for them optimal decision special so
then okay